this is an interesting point because um
potentially what was the start of the
culture depending you asked gamergate
you're familiar
this is this was a lot of people who
identified themselves as left
libertarian on the political spectrum
being angered that everything was
becoming political because you had these
uh quote unquote news organizations
video game you know news and video game
companies
increasingly putting very specific
ideologies in their games and people
were upset with that right so they would
agree with you like why are we
politicizing everything please don't
bring me into gamergate man i mean
i was playing heroes of the storm last
night on blizzard and i was like if i
type f the ccp am i going to get banned
off of blizzard i didn't test it but i
was wondering well there are certain
things that that youtube banned but uh
you know to the point about um
you know politicizing everything yeah
video games did used to have a lot of
politics in them but it was more of like
background acceptable american views
when they started becoming
very different like um you know uh at
core like marxist
having some kind of like marxist tinge
to a lot of them what do you mean by
marxist so
i i will say in america that word has a
meaning that i mean i mean understand in
the true sense of marxist ideology of
oppressed versus oppressor
well so like okay i would i mean
like
mark to me marxism is
there's lots of oppressed versus
oppressor ideologies but marxism to me
is strictly a class-based struggle all
other all other structures are
invalidated no but that that that was a
a key point i mean i think around occupy
wall street we had the very much
class-based narrative of the one percent
well exactly occupy wall street to me is
cloud is that's that's a mark's a
struggle but video games almost can't be
i mean he rejects is that he rejects any
aesthetic category well so are you
familiar with the origins of critical
race theory yeah but that's not i mean
to me that's
that's not marxism i mean you know
i think it i think it has come it has
come to mean something in this country
that i i just don't recognize in my own
like in my own readings of marxism in my
own readings of
i'm certainly con like to me that that's
a that's an identity politics
formulation which is a completely
separate thing well when it comes to
like roblox you want to talk about video
games enslaving people in a class-based
system that's what it is totally off
subject okay so critical race theory
specifically kimberly crenshaw wrote
that marx didn't understand american
racial politics and that the idea of a
press versus oppressor can't just be
class-based when race is inherently tied
to class right
yeah but i mean
that's inherently a rejection of marxism
right like i mean
right like that like marx is like in the
jewish question he says
you know there are there there are no
there aren't effect no ethnicities all
there is is class so i think so to me
like you know like th this whole reading
of martial it's a semantic issue though
that's what i was saying i guess so but
like it does seem to me pretty important
that like the this because because
marxism conjured so much evil in the
world right like because it because it
conjured so many totalitarian regimes
like to call something marxist to me is
like
that i mean that's kind of the ultimate
insult because it was ultimately
so evil right and
for like that's not what that's not what
applies to these other forms let me let
me bring you there so uh i went down to
occupy wall street on like day three and
right you were right so you know i ended
up streaming and stuff but
it started out with conservatives
libertarians liberals and leftists all
in one place
saying we very much oppose the bailouts
the corruption in the system the
revolving door policies in the first
week there was so much talk about these
big banks got bailed out the the guy who
works for the pharmaceutical companies
gets a job with the fda the guy from the
war machine halliburton becomes the vice
president it's a revolving door sure but
within about two weeks
critical race theory took over
and all of a sudden you couldn't speak
at their assemblies if you were a white
man and if you wanted to speak or i
should say you're at the bottom of the
list on their progressive stack right so
it started out as
in
essentially marxist the the class-based
oppression yeah quickly turned into a
bunch of intersectionalists critical
race theorists coming in and saying no
no you guys don't understand
race is actually the core component and
then all of a sudden the narrative there
shifted the libertarians and
conservatives left and that this was one
of the start the starting points at
least in the culture war that i've
experienced yeah well this is what i'm
talking about when i'm talking about
self-defeating left-wing politics like
this is what i was talking about
like
like what is required from the left now
more than ever in a complete sense is
solidarity and it is completely
incapable of providing that even on the
most basic levels
right and that's why to me like
because my my book what my book is about
is about collapsing systems right and
and how systems collapse and like what
is causing the collapse of systems and
the left is actually too weak
to cause a collapse of the system
because it eats itself in five minutes
that's why occupy wall street went
nowhere but that's technically not true
well occupy wall street resulted in a
massive shift of wealth from for-profit
to credit unions and it resulted in i
think the democratic party pulled their
money out of bank of america and moved
it to amalgamated which is a union
operated oh yeah so uh oh there how much
was that
uh the dnc's funds i don't know i can't
remember
tens of millions maybe
tens of millions i mean like i'm talking
about the united states of america but
it's it's a big uh you know you plant
the seed of a cultural shift and that
and that matters
so when i look at occupy wall street and
i see the rise of what was effectively a
form of if it was overtly critical race
theory and then makes its way into
something bigger into media it expands
that was the first experience i had with
it it was kind of a crazy experience to
see how racist they were i mean overtly
separating people into different racial
categories to make them vote on policy
was insane do you think you would
qualify as someone who was comp like the
process of complementary radicalization
would apply to you oh yeah absolutely
yeah that's interesting so uh so how do
you like
how do you
negotiate that i'm curious there's like
do you like because you know the way
that they think about it the way that
the experts that i talk to think about
it is like a an inverse pendulum so like
as a pendulum swings
you know it tends to the center but in
american politics it tends
the energy sends it to more extreme
forms right we're not seeing the same
level of
extremism on the right as we are on the
left
oh i disagree i mean i would have to
disagree with you there
like i mean
you see there's there's all kinds of
right-wing extremism i mean there's and
and and the other thing about extremism
on the right is also way better armed
well let's let's let's let's talk about
some examples
january 6th we got that's a big one for
sure there you go
but what else the oath keepers list 40
000 people what do they do what have
they done
well january 6th i mean but look january
6 you had uh
800 people
well i mean certainly like they're
relatively different okay well the the
extreme right in the united states is of
course really hard to figure out um you
know the way i think of it is as a um
like a smorgasbord of ideologies some
that are completely incompatible and
some that are so there's
the left too oh the left is totally
chaotic yeah it's all right like it's
like like i i
i mean for my own sake i think we can
just dismiss the left as a as a force
right because in america because it is
so disorganized and it eats itself right
um
so what you see on the right is like
there are sovereign citizens there are
three percenters there are uh you know
uh oath keepers there there are
sagebrush rebels there are
uh you know um second amendment
absolutists there are tax evasion people
there are
tax wooden people so
what have they done well of the
political murders of every year which
are amount to like about 70 on average
since 2015 uh i think the the number
don't quote me because it's in the it's
in the book and i don't have it on my
fingertips but i think it's like 72
percent are far right and like seven
percent are far left and the middle is
like
various so like i would say like when i
talk to the experts um the the fear of
political violence is is much clearer
from the right and that's why i said i
feel like the fire is more sharp right
when they do take action yeah it's
extreme well you know we're also dealing
i think we should acknowledge this
because we are all trying to stay human
beings here
is that we're dealing with a lot of
people who are on the line between
mental illness and political affiliation
we're dealing with a lot of people who
are criminal
who are just simply criminals and use
politics as a cover for their violence
and like that has to be acknowledged too
right and that this and that this
political radicalization gives them
cover for
mental illness and for and for their
violence right so those things all like
also those numbers like to be clear are
not from the fbi they're from they're
from they're from
journalist reporting organizations who
are going through newspapers to figure
out what are violent and they're
defining right yeah well they're they're
trying to pick up the pieces but
honestly this this work has not been
done at a government level it's only and
it's been done in an academic but
i want to get back to that point because
i don't think we got a chance to flush
it out yeah so my point was that um
there's uh substantially more far left
polarization and extremism compared to
the right and i'll and i'll to to make
my point
let me ask you a question if you went to
a uh
would you fear violence against you at a
right-wing rally
um i've got i've always gone along
really well with far-right people like i
quite like them like i like i i um but
just just real quick for the sake of
argument you you wouldn't really oh i
definitely would you well they're i mean
when you go to a far-right rally there
are many many people walking around with
large weapons i don't know what a
far-right rally is so so so just
you know uh i've been on the ground for
uh uh i went on the ground for maybe
also i look like this i mean i'm like
i'm like a white dude from alberta so
you you'd be more likely to get attacked
by the far left
well i don't i've never felt threatened
by the far left now
um
you know i'll give you i'll give you
excuses let me give you an example like
i attended the 2016 inauguration i
covered it for a canadian magazine uh
the what i fear genuinely is not really
either side it's when the two sides are
together
like that's what's scary donald trump's
inauguration yeah there were there were
about 400 black-clad leftists smashing
windows starting fires and and attacking
people in the streets yeah there were
there were plenty of far-right groups
there too but they weren't doing
anything well
they were sort of triumphantly there too
well there was there was some violence
but i i would say that the atmosphere of
menace like you're you're just asking me
my feelings right so so it's just you
know it's
my personal experience but there's also
a really big you look like you looked
him yeah i mean like if you were if you
were a black woman and you were at a
far-right rally i think that would be a
completely different thing and like
that's one of the things that i've
always found like
far right people get along with me very
very well like i like talking to them
they're
like they're they're nice guys like like
honestly like they're they're not
they're perfectly polite you want to
know what i saw in portland
i saw the far
screaming the n-word over and over again
at right-wingers i saw the proud boys
with a bunch of different people of
different races and there was a black
proud boy who was walking down the
street and antifa was screaming
incessantly the n-word at him i've been
on the ground on all these things daryl
davis we have very different experiences
of these things for sure are you
familiar with daryl davis no i don't
know who that is he's the black jazz
musician who
he decided you know he thought to
himself one day how could someone hate
me if they don't know me so he started
going to clan meetings oh yes that guy
yeah he's fantastic and we booked him to
speak at an event called ending what was
it called ending violence
uh racism and authoritarianism he was
our keynote our headline speaker to talk
about de-radicalization antifa
threatened to burn the theater down so
they canceled on us
the the after show venue refused to back
down so antifa came and protested and he
said
look guys don't worry i'm gonna go talk
to him and when he went out there they
started screaming at him chanting at him
and wouldn't let him speak he wrote a
facebook post which went viral where he
said i've never experienced anything
like this that i was able to go and talk
to clan members as a black man but he
couldn't even talk to these leftist
activists outside without them screaming
at him well look all i can tell you is
the experts i talk to the people that
study this stuff
are much more afraid of the right than
the left now could it be that they are
on the left
well i would they're from foreign
countries
so so the answer is yes
i guess so i mean if they're from
belgium yes they're on the left well i
think see i'm gonna go back to i'm gonna
go back to one thing you said
i think if you went to i haven't been to
a far-right rally i've been to trump
rallies
my experience have been has been that if
you are a black woman people will go so
much further out of their way to be
accommodating because they want to
demonstrate that much more
that they are not racist because they
have been pinned by the left as you are
a trump person you must be a racist can
i just and i think i find that amazing
that that that
that's what has to be done but that is
what happens don't you think that time
has come
to stop asking yourselves who is more to
blame
and start figuring out
either how do we reconcile this or how
do we come to some kind of conclusion
that is not violent i mean
you're you're talking about like
all of this stuff like you're like look
at you you're getting yourselves really
angry about this oh god no i don't not
in the slightest bit no no look
no no no that's not fair just because
it's a heated conversation it's not
listen listen i'm not i'm not blaming
anyone i'm just saying like the point of
this book
is really that the moment has come where
you have to ask yourself
how do we get ourselves out of this
cycle of of those people are awful oh
we're all people our people are awful
but that's in response like that's the
crisis that is facing you is no longer
one of who is right but like how do you
how do you work out these structures
into a way well here's a civilized and
and that is civilized and is you kill it
i know the answer you got to give them
something to live for and you got to
unify people i just said with a with an
idea civil war is the worst thing that
can happen oh for sure death is the
worst
being conquered by a foreign country is
nothing compared to civil war it's the
like
it's the worst thing that can happen to
a country it's a disaster china will
come in if this escalates so well you're
gonna need like in part of the book i'm
like imagining what it would be like to
have a negotiated settlement with the
united states which would have to be
internationally monitored and we love
that in this country yeah
we love foreign america live more than
chinese peacekeepers on the ground again
i have my bias and i'm very well aware
that i have my bias so so no bones about
it but so go after me but let me make my
point yeah so you said when you talk
when you look at political
assassinations or political murders
based on you said those numbers were
based on journalists who dig into the
assassination is separate not
assassination murders political violence
and you they were done based on
journalists who dug into the story and
read it in five years from now if a
journalist reads an op-ed
in the las vegas post which talked about
um
the black lives matter uh attempted
murder in louisville they called him a
right-wing trump supporter basically
they said that this is the cause of
right-wing violence and they said
although he is not and if you read the
op-ed and i sent it to lydia because i
was so apoplectic if you if you as of
now he has not been identified to any
right-wing groups but this is trump
violence this is this is an editorial in
the las vegas sun after it came out that
he was a black lives matter activist so
you want to say to that editorial board
what are you doing but like why are you
writing a story saying this is a
right-wing extremist who shot a jewish
tried to kill a jewish man running for
for mayor when all of the evidence there
says he is a left-wing radical but but
i'll answer that
uh okay and then i want to make answer a
point you made i don't want to hear your
answer to my question because like i
think you're a very interesting case of
somebody who has lived through
complementary radicalization and i would
like to know how you
see escaping from it there isn't an
escape but the the uh to your point
they're
it's a conflict yeah they're going to
say what they need to say to support
their side by any means by any means
necessary and so you actually have
groups called like by any means
necessary the reason why there is no
escape so you asked me if um i am uh i
phrase it but like if i am subject to
complementary
well i i i'm curious like i don't know
if i like i don't know you but i would
like i i you seem to me like you would
fit into that category that i've seen
sociologists describe i mean maybe
that's not fair and if it's not please
tell me no no
it is without a doubt but um i don't i i
think
the the issue at hand is
what's the best example to give um
the truckers in in canada are really
great example
i supported occupy wall street
their right to protest
i interviewed people on the ground
i defended
extinction rebellion when they blocked
the streets in in dc and put up a boat
and said we demand to be heard when ron
desantis was working in florida on the
anti-riot law i said it is wrong to make
it a felony to block a road those who
make peaceful revolution impossible make
violent revolution inevitable
see i'm the opposite i want them all
banned
but here's what happens
the same people that i met 10 years ago
who defended the right to occupy streets
are now opposed to it
in ottawa well so it was a very
different situation because it's been
going on for three weeks and occupy wall
street went on for two months well i was
supposed to occupy wall street and you
also had the chas and the chop you also
had minneapolis but it's not about yours
it's not about your views right it's
about the fact that we have
we have in this country
two parent factions
within those parent factions we describe
them as left and right it's fairly
nebulous you have several smaller groups
many of them don't like each other
antifa people don't like democrats but
often they hate them but their politics
do align sometimes
well barely but but institutionally
right so the democrats support black
lives matter to try and earn votes which
then gives funding to say the federal
government gave funding for for covet
relief that the illinois government then
gave directly to black lives matter i
believe it was 300 000 that would never
happen with the oath keepers that would
never happen with the proud boys in fact
the proud boys get called terrorists and
evil and demonized thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you